so
let me ask you've read quite a few
papers
you've uh annotated quite a few papers
let's talk about the process itself how
do you advise people read papers
or maybe you want to broaden it beyond
just papers but just
read
concrete pieces of information to
understand the insights that lay within
i would say for paper specifically i
would bring back kind of what louise was
talking about it is that it's important
to keep in mind that papers are not
optimized for ease of understanding and
so right there's all sorts of
restrictions in size
and format and and language that they
can use and so it's important to keep
that in mind and so that if you're
struggling to read a paper doesn't
that might not mean that the underlying
material is actually that hard and so
so that's definitely something that that
especially for us that we we we read
papers and most of the times they'll be
papers are completely outside of our of
our comfort zone i guess
and and to be completely new areas to us
um
so i always try to to keep that in mind
so there's usually a certain kind of
structure like abstract introductions
methodology
uh depending on the community and so on
is there something about
the process of like
how to read it whether you want to skim
it to try to find the parts that are
easy to understand or not
reading it multiple times
is there any kind of hacks that you can
comment on i remember like feynman had
these this kind of hack when he was
reading papers where
he would basically
um
would i think i believe he would read
the conclusion of the paper
and we would try to just um see if he
would be able to figure out how to get
to the conclusion in like a couple of
minutes by himself
and um and he would read a lot of papers
that way
and i think fermi also did that almost
and fermi was known for doing a lot of
back of the envelope calculation so he
was a master at doing that um
in terms of like especially when
when reading a paper i think a lot of
times people might
feel discouraged about the first time
you read it
you know it's very hard to grasp or you
don't understand a huge fraction of the
paper
and i think it's having read a lot of
papers in my life i think i've in peace
with like the fact that you might spend
hours where you're just reading a paper
and jumping from paper to paper reading
citations
and um like your level of understanding
of sometimes of the paper is very close
to zero percent and all of a sudden you
know everything kind of
makes sense and and in your mind and
then you know you have this quantum jump
where all of a sudden you you you
understanding the big picture of the
paper and uh i i
and and this is an exercise that i have
to when reading papers and especially
like more complex papers like okay you
don't understand because you're just
going through the process and just keep
going and like and it it's it might feel
super chaotic especially if you are
jumping from reference to reference you
know you might end up with like 20 tabs
open and you're reading a ton of other
papers but it's just trusting that
process
that at the end like you'll find light
and i think for me that's a good
framework when reading a paper it's hard
because you know you might end up
spending a lot of time and you it looks
like you're lost
but uh but
that's the process to actually
understand what they're talking about in
a paper
yeah i think that process i enjoy i've
found a lot of value in the process
especially for things outside my field
of reading a lot of related work
sections and kind of go going down that
path of getting a big context of the
field because what's especially when
they're well written
there's opinions injected into the
related work like what work is important
what is not and if you read multiple
related work sections that cite or don't
cite each other like the papers
you get a sense of where the field where
the tensions of the field are
where this where the field is striving
and that helps you put into context like
whether the work is radical
whether it's overselling it self whether
it's underselling itself all those
things uh and on adding on top of that
i find that often the related work
section
is the most
kind of accessible and readable part of
a paper
because it's kind of uh it's brief to
the point it's trying like summarizing
it's almost like a wikipedia style
article the introduction is supposed to
be a compelling story or whatever but
it's often like overselling there's like
an agenda in the introduction
the related work usually has the least
amount of agenda except for the few
like elements where you're trying to uh
talk [ __ ] about previous work where
you're trying to sell that you're doing
much better but other than that when
you're just painting where the where the
field
came from or where the field stands
that's really valuable and also again
just to agree with finding the
conclusion it's like i get a lot of
value from the breadth first search kind
of read the conclusion
then read the related work and then
uh go through the references in the
related work read the conclusion read
the related work and just go down the
tree until you like hit dead ends or run
out of coffee and then through that
process you go back up the tree and now
you can see the results in their proper
in their proper context unless of course
the paper is truly revolutionary which
even that process will help you
understand that is in fact
truly
revolutionary
you